[Musik]
ich grüße sie liebe zuschauer renault
zuschauer
salvo liegt in einem tal umgeben von
bergen in einer pittoresken landschaft
aber wer in die stadt hinein gehen sieht
überall einschusslöcher sogenannte rosen
von sarah welcher auf dem boden die mit
roter farbe gefüllt sind weil dort vier
oder mehr menschen von einer bombe
getötet wurden vor 30 jahren begann
nämlich die belagerung der stadt st sie
dauerte fast vier jahre forderte über
11.000 menschen leben sowie zehntausende
von verletzten was ist aus dem
sehnsuchtsort dem vorzeigemodell reibung
geworden welche rolle spielt die
religion in der region und was können
wir auch in zusammenhang des krieges in
der ukraine aus den kriegen im
ehemaligen jugoslawien lernen darüber
spreche ich heute mit nina bott
journalistin und filmemacherin und dem
journalisten enver robelli herzlich
willkommen
sie kommen nun direkt aus davos zu uns
wo sie gerade einen dokumentarfilm
drehen
hawaii wo eine vom krieg gezeichnete
stadt wie wird dort der krieg in der
ukraine wahrgenommen
also es ist so eine
balance als einerseits fällt es den
menschen sehr schwer werden rät
romantisiert wenn sie diese bilder sehen
also geht es uns eigentlich bei allen
kriegen wir füllen immer mit bei der
ukraine ist nochmal spezifischer weil
die architektur so ähnlich ist dienstag
aber bei manchen bildern aus kiel wo
daraus mario pohl denke ich mir das
sieht genauso aus wie meine
nachbarschaft
und dann zusehen wie diese gebäude diese
aus den hass ob sie bei uns sind
bombardiert werden und zu wissen dass
die gebäude eigentlich das kleinste
problem sind sondern die menschen die
dort ihr leben verlieren das ist für uns
so sehr schwer andererseits ist es auch
so ein bisschen bitter für uns wenn wir
sehen wie viel unterstützung die ukraine
bekommt wir sind natürlich absolut dafür
und wir möchten auch unterstützen aber
bei uns damals war nicht mal die rede
von waffen liefern und so weiter wie es
bei der ukraine gemacht wird im
gegenteil bei uns gab es ein
waffenembargo
wir durften nicht mal selbst waffen
irgendwie kaufen oder bekommen und das
hauptproblem darin ist als bosnien
angegriffen wurde es wurde angegriffen
von der jugoslawischen armee welche die
viertgrößte militärmacht europas war und
bosnien war zwar schon unabhängig aber
hatte gar keine armee also in einer
situation wo ein angriffskrieg ist und
eine riesige militärmacht gegen menschen
kämpft die nicht mal ein militär haben
und dann wird noch gesagt ihr dürft auch
keine waffen kaufen das ist für uns sehr
bitter heute zu sehen wie anders das ist
bei der ukraine
ja ich glaube über diese struktur
ähnlichkeit tun die folgen kommen wir
gleichen sprechen aber es zunächst
einmal müssen wir doch feststellen und
30 jahre sind es tatsächlich vergangen
nach der belagerung der stadt sarajevo
und ich habe den eindruck
gerade weil wir gerade im kontext des
ukraine krieges immer wieder hören
mussten das ist der erste krieg und
europa nach dem zweiten weltkrieg sei
dass der
balkankrieg die belagerung sarajevos
doch so einem sagen wir vergessenen
krieg gehört daher wäre es vielleicht
wichtig kann man fallen eine historische
einordnung vorzunehmen
herr o'barry sie stammen selbst aus dem
kosovo leben aber schon lange in der
schweiz
journalistisch tätig unter anderem auch
für digitales anzeige
mögen sie uns erzählen in kürze das ist
genau dort passiert
kurz kann man sagen dass nach dem tod
des jugoslawischen für josip broz tito
anfang der 80er jahren und 180 dann zu
ethnischen spannungen im ganzen land
gekommen ist die nationalistischen
kräfte sind viel stärker geworden die
wirtschaftslage ist viel schlimmer
geworden jugoslawien war ein hoch
verschuldeter staat
und so haben dann die nationalisten die
oberhand gewonnen und zwar auf
verschiedenen seiten aber natürlich vor
allem auf der serbischen seite
und es gab überhaupt keine einigung
zwischen den politischen führen so hat
man dann die jugoslawische armee
eigentlich zu einer serbischen armee
umgewandelt dieser armee hat dann die
nachbars völker angegriffen und das
ganze ist dann eskaliert anfang april
1992 als sarajevo belagert wurde das
sind tausende von menschen auf die
straße gegangen haben eigentlich gegen
diesen krieg gegen diesen angekündigten
krieg protestiert es hat leider nichts
gebracht weil die nationalistischen
kräfte sehr sehr stark war vor allem auf
der serbischen seite und so hat man die
belagerung sarajevos begonnen mit
fatalen folgen also es ist die längste
belagerung eines staates in der modernen
geschichte
1425 tage mit sie haben es gesagt mit
11.000 toten darunter 1600 kinder mit
unglaublich viel zerstörten gebäuden mit
man hat eigentlich versucht die seele
dieser stadt zu vernichten und man muss
man muss ein bisschen auch resigniert
auch sagen ein bisschen ist es den
nationalisten auch gelungen die säle
salons soweit zu zerstören und die
ethnische entflechtung zu
bewerkstelligen also das ist
mehrheitlich leider gelungen also
sarajevo ist heute nicht mehr die multi
ethnische stadt die es in den 80er
jahren war ja darauf können wir gleich
zu sprechen die die erfahrungen dieser
fiel sehr sehr verpflichtet ist und
viele konflikte ihm zusammen führt ist
auch etwas was natürlich auch
existenziell die menschen auch betroffen
hat mich meine sie waren selbst damals
die bosnien sind dort geboren als kind
und musste mit ihrer familie dann auch
den krieg erleben und von dort aus auch
pflichten haben sie noch erinnerungen
wie sie damals den krieg erlebt haben
am ja natürlich also selbst wenn man
sehr kleines das sind einfach sachen die
sich einprägen und es ist etwas worüber
man nicht so sehr nachdenken möchte weil
es so schmerzhaft ist so dass ich erst
vor ein paar jahren eigentlich die
realisation hatte ich bin gar nicht vor
einem krieg geflüchtet sondern von einem
genozid weil wir ja schon gerade sagte
bastian hatte gar keine armee wurde denn
da bekämpft wer hat sich bekämpft weil
sich flüchten musste das war nur boris
gemetzel in meiner stadt hat niemand
keine einzige bosniakisch oder muss
wieder und wieder muss er zwei jahre alt
und am anfang und dann natürlich ging es
noch viele jahre weiter und die
nachkriegszeit war ja auch nicht viel
besser ich kann mich erinnern ich bin in
einer sehr besonderen nachbarstadt
nachbarschaft aufgewachsen gräber witze
und das seien teils sei der bus der
nicht mal belagert war sondern auch
kopiert der war die serbische armee drin
und die menschen durften zum beispiel
ihre wohnungen nicht abschließen
also wir wissen das uno tribunal hat ja
festgelegt dass es in bosnien
konzentrationslager vergewaltigungs
lager und vernichtungslager gehabt zu
sagen wie obwohl das eigentlich eine
nachbarschaft ist wir sagen das war so
ein open-air konzentrationslager die
menschen waren zwar in ihren wohnungen
aber waren komplett dem terror der
serbische nationalisten ausgesetzt
das natürlich auch frauen die sie als
kind nicht hätten machen können sie
neben kindlich alles war und das ist sie
haben es beschrieben chaos gemetzel
flucht
hingegen waren während des krieges auch
im kosovo ja nicht dort sondern hier in
der schweiz wir haben es ja nicht den
krieg erlebt
vor allem als journalist als beobachter
nicht als akteur und da bin ich sehr
froh darüber
natürlich
ist man nicht gegen einen krieg nie
unbeteiligt auch jetzt in der ukraine
das nimmt uns mit da spielen emotionen
mit auch wenn man dann in der region
noch verwandte hat das ist natürlich
schwierig dieser situation umzugehen
ich bin froh dass natürlich 99 die
westliche gemeinschaft im unterschied
zur post in dem falle kosovos dann nach
einem jahr
krieg im kosovo oder die nato
interveniert hat und dem
gemetzel ingo so ein ende gesetzt hat
aber mit einer uno mit einer nato
intervention und mit einer westlichen
intervention ende der krieg nie das geht
dann weiter weil die gesellschaft sicher
neu organisieren muss sich neu sortieren
muss und das sieht man auch in bosnien
auch im kosovo das ist vielleicht auch
in einer karte genauer uns das anschauen
weil das kannst du natürlich auch wie
gesagt zu den vergessenen krieg gehört
auch eine bestimmte rhetorik machen dass
er acht uns nämlich das ganze als einen
balkankriegs du bist reichen dann ist
das zumindest nicht ganz europäisch
insofern
vielleicht an der karte selbst also das
siehst du wir haben wir sehen ihren
vielvölkerstaat
kosovo ist mittendrin
und auch betroffen und sie stelle ich
mir vor wie in der schweiz sind
journalistisch tätig aber was ich hier
nicht abnehmen der journalist ich das
gerne zu beobachten dass muss jedoch
auch betroffen haben ja gut es betrifft
uns natürlich auch was den menschen
jetzt
geschieht in kiew und das ist natürlich
schon wenn man eine rgb herkunft hat
dann interessiert man sich natürlich
noch mehr für eine gewisse regierung
aber ich bin hier aufgewachsen und ich
war schon damals journalistisch tätig
aber klar das lässt ein micoud ja klar
und vor allem die die die schweiz hat ja
auch eine besondere rolle in diesem
ganzen spiel auch in diesem ganzen
perfiden spiel sind flüchtlinge die
nicht nur nach deutschland sondern auch
in die schweiz kommen und für die
generation ist dass auch die erste
erfahrung mit menschen die vom krieg
gezeichnet sind sie sind teil der
schweizer kultur und identität heute die
fast fußball nationalmannschaft der
schweiz kann man nicht kaum vorstellen
ohne die menschen die auch aus dieser
region eigentlich
ein stamm
insofern geht es uns auch in der schweiz
dieser konflikt doch etwas an ja klar
allerdings muss man sagen dass während
des kosovo-krieges die schweiz 50.000
kosovo albanischer flüchtlinge
aufgenommen hat und dass sie nach dem
griechenland zurück das wird dann in der
schweiz immer wieder auch vergessen aber
es gab natürlich dass es die dann sehr
gastarbeiter generation der 60er und
70er jahre die sind die sind dann da
geblieben das ist schon so und heute
leben etwa 2 200 200.000 kosovo albaner
oder kosten albanisch stämmigen menschen
in der schweiz insgesamt aus dem ganzen
balkan vermutlich etwa eine halbe
million
das ist ja noch das ist genommen sie
sind damals nach deutschland
geflüchtet wie haben sie diese flucht
wahrgenommen die sind noch sehr jung mit
ihrer familie bisher nicht wirklich wo
es hingeht und kommen in einem dorf in
deutschland dran
ja also es war erst mal so eine zickzack
flucht quer durch europa und
dann waren ja eigentlich ganz froh als
sie in diesen containern untergebracht
worden weil alles was wir davor hatten
war viel schlimmer und ich kann mich
noch erinnern dass wir neun menschen in
zwei containern waren die waren ungefähr
so vielleicht 15 quadratmeter zusammen
und dann wir neun den waltons jemand
einen spiegel
schenken so als hilfe weil wir da
natürlich nichts hatten meine tante
meine meinte so nein nein dann hören wir
ja noch doppelt so viele und es war
eigentlich
relativ okay zeit weil natürlich aus
heutiger perspektive denken menschen das
flüchtlingen grausam geht und das ist ja
auch so aber für uns das größte problem
war dass wir wussten dass es unseren
familien noch schlimmer gibt dass wir
uns so sehr so viele sorgen gemacht
haben und die stadt in der ein großer
teil meiner familie war weil die waren
ja dann binnenflüchtlinge weil in meiner
stadt niemand überlebt hat da war auch
eine riesige hungersnot und ich habe
jetzt noch schuldgefühle service gilt
dass ich eigentlich immer zu essen hatte
während meine familie fast gestorben war
alle zehn herausgefallen sie haben gras
gegessen teilweise haben das sind alles
dinge die heute vergessen sind der
gesamte krieg in bosnien und gesamten
gesamte genozid werden auch sonst
reduziert obwohl das im ganzen land
grausamer
einen augenblick aus seinem
film den wir selbst gemacht haben über
die kinder des krieges so der
kriegskinder aus bosnien geht mir nicht
aus dem kopf sie stehen in diesem dorf
in dem sie ja damals er geflüchtet waren
sehen zum ersten mal die menschen die
nachbarn die sie damals herzlich
aufgenommen haben
nach einem geselligen gesprächen stehen
sie da und
prächtig sind sie unglaublich gerührt
als wäre der ganze schmerz
in ihm wieder gekehrt nicht saß da und
musste für einen augenblick wirklich
tief einatmen
was hat sie genau gerührt
es ist
eigentlich ist es so ein dauer gerührt
sein also immer wenn ich über diese
themen nachdenke nicht nur in diesem
moment immer ist es sehr schwierig und
in dem moment es war einfach so
eine welle von gefühlen von
eigentlich ist es ja ein schöner ort und
die sonne scheint und guck mal wie schön
wir das damals hatten
und dann so schild gefühl dass es meiner
familie anders ging und auch heute
natürlich möchte ich flüchtlingen helfen
aus anderen ländern und das mache ich
auch aber ich finde es manchmal manchmal
problematisch dass wir die menschen in
den kriegszonen vergessen dass soviel
der hilfe an menschen geht dies
eigentlich relativ obwohl das natürlich
auch hat ist relativ gut haben und das
war in bosnien auch so als wir dann
zurückgekehrt sind wurden wir nicht mit
offenen armen empfangen es gab einen
großen hass auf flüchtlinge sogar auf
die kinder nach dem motto ihr seid der
satyr ihr habt uns allein gelassen
also war man irgendwie nie so richtig
sagt so gehörig zu dem konflikt gehört
auch dass es eine komplexe angelegenheit
ist wir reden von
technischen fragen wir reden aber auch
von von religiösen fragen
welche rolle spielte dort die religion
ich glaube die region wurde von der
serbischen seite missbraucht um die
bosnischen muslime zu attackieren
das ist ich kenne keine gesellschaft
muslimische gesellschaft in europa die
toleranter war als als die bosnisch
muslimische gesellschaft natürlich gab
es im krieg versuche die bosnischen
muslime auch von auswärtigen kräften zu
radikalisieren das ist aber nicht
gelungen die politische führung der
bosnischen muslime war auch während des
krieges säkular
europäisch orientiert
auch nach dem krieg gab es versuche
natürlich von von auswärts aber so kann
man auch sagen dass es gibt auch
versuche von verschiedenen von der
russisch-orthodoxen kirche natürlich
auch einfluss zu nehmen also das wird
dann gern auch verschwiegen
so gesehen finde ich finde ich
einen unglaublichen einen unglaublichen
verlust eigentlich das dass dieser krieg
auch mit mitgebracht hat nicht nur dass
dieser multi ethnische gesellschaft im
großen und ganzen nicht mehr existiert
sondern was auch zwischen den menschen
sehr viele brücken zerstört worden sind
zwischen muslimen
christlichen serben römisch katholischen
kroaten und das setzt sich weiter fort
auch heute
natürlich sind die
gesellschaften oder diese drei
volksgruppen nach dem krieg religiöser
geworden weil die
klammer die das ganze jahr zusammen
gehalten hat der jugoslawische
kommunismus die parole von der
brüderlichkeit und einheit die gibt es
nicht mehr natürlich war das auch ein
bisschen verlogen und man hat auch
verschwiegen dass im zweiten weltkrieg
natürlich neben dem heldenhaften kampf
der partisanen gegen die nazis auch
einen innere jugoslawischen bürgerkrieg
gab aber diese parole hat natürlich
schon und die ganze propaganda der
kommunistischen partei hat natürlich
gewisse debatten unterdrückt und man hat
sich damit abgefunden
was war nicht dass das irgendwie
katholische element von diesem
vielvölkerstaat dass sie alles so
einheit auch gebracht hat ja klar die
die ganze jugoslawische idee die
slawische idee erst im jahr am schluss
alle slawischen völker es braucht einen
posten gebraucht in belgrad keine
übersetzung mit einem serben zu sprechen
wenn gerade auch nicht obwohl sich nach
dem krieg wieder behauptete hätte jetzt
eine eigene sprache
natürlich auch die grundidee als
jugoslawien 1918 das erste überschlagen
gegründet wurde sehr viele völker so die
slowenen die grotten oder wie er liegt
ein teil der elite die wollten weg vom
von der kaum kommen aktiv an der donau
monarchie und haben eigentlich die
jugoslawische idee unterstützt also es
ist ja nicht so dass man sagen kann es
war nun eine serbische idee einen
jugoslawischen staat zu gründen um in
jugoslawien zu dominieren also da gab es
natürlich durchaus kräfte auch in den
anderen
also bei anderen völkern um jugoslawien
jugoslawien zu gründen das problem ist
dass es später eigentlich zu einem groß
serbien unter dem namen jugoslawien
wurde weil ich meine allein schon der
name jugoslawien albaner sind keine
sklaven die meisten jüdischen menschen
auf diesen gebieten sind keine sklaven
nummer sind keine sklaven
und dann das ist jetzt eine lange
geschichte auf der in der kosovarischen
hauptrolle spielt wieder die menschen
unterdrückt wurden aber dann hat mir los
stellt die hälfte der macht im land
gehabt also es gab acht stimmen im
präsidium service nach tito und er hat
vier kontrolliert dadurch dass er
kostenlos und worüber denn als stimme
gestohlen hat und die serbische hatte
und in montenegro jemanden installiert
hat und dann musste das
auseinanderfallen slowenien hat zuerst
gesagt wir können nicht in einem land
leben das sagt wir sind vielvölkerstadt
aber ein serbischer nationalist
entscheidet die hälfte und diese idee
von gross serbien die zieht sich ja
schon jahrhundertelang da gibt es
dokumente in dem gesagt wird ja wir
werden zum beispiel die hälfte der
kroaten töten die andere hälfte
vertreiben die albaner alle töten was
merken auch alle töten und so weiter und
so fort die hatten das numerische
durchgerechnet alles also es eine lange
geschichte die leider auch vergessen ist
ich will noch einmal zurückkommen auf
die ganze geschichte die nicht
aufgearbeitet wurde und sonders spielt
der zweite weltkrieg natürlich auch eine
rolle und da muss man sagen dass
natürlich in kroatien es gab ja eine
marionettenregierung eine nazi
freundliche regierung die hat im zweiten
weltkrieg tausende serben ermordet diese
geschichte wurde leider auch nicht
aufgearbeitet damit will ich überhaupt
nicht den serbischen nationalismus
kleinreden das war natürlich eine
katastrophe dafür hat serbien auch ein
preis bezahlt nachdem in all diesen
kriegen also wenn man heute sieht zum
beispiel
diese haben stellten zwölf prozent etwa
zwölf prozent der bevölkerung kroatien
und mittlerweile ist das jahr reduziert
auf 34 prozent weil die meisten dann
flüchten mussten nachdem die kroatische
armee die serbisch besetzten gebiete
zurückerobert hat viele wurden auch
vertrieben also es ist natürlich am
schluss spielen kriegerische
abenteurerin eine fatale rolle für alle
gesellschaften aber man muss sagen zum
beispiel in bosnien das darf man nicht
vergessen 80 prozent der opfer sind
bosnische muslime wenn man so aus
westlicher bequemlichkeit einfach so von
einem bürgerkrieg spricht das bedeutet
ja dass alle irgendwie in alle
richtungen geschossen haben jeder hat
auf den anderen
handlung angegriffen das ist leider oder
das ist nicht so es ist einfach das
entspricht nicht den historischen
tatsachen
ich meine so dem gehört haben wir über
die gegenwart jetzt auch sprechen wo sie
auch jetzt andeutungen gemacht haben es
scheint so als sei wo dann auch in
gewisser weise auch grundlegend
verändert es ist nicht mehr dieser multi
ethnische was fenster wo haben sie
eigentlich wieder gefunden also wieder
zurückgekehrt sind abgeschoben wurden na
ja also das sollte wo ich war in der
nachbarschaft wo die serbische armee war
er wurde vor dem rückzug haben die alles
verbrannt haben sie alles verdient wir
haben in unserer wohnung im schlafzimmer
zwei bomben gefunden und das war keine
wichtige wohnung die haben einfach
versucht irgendwen zu tippen auf dem
spielplatz meiner grundschule da waren
neue minen versteckt gezielt um kinder
zu töten sie hatten als schulfach
landminen sicherheit weil wir das hatten
mussten haben mussten ich habe heute
immer noch so ein komisches gefühl wenn
ich über gras laufe weil ich gelernt
habe einfach als kind immer auf beton zu
laufen immer geradeaus nichts hoch zu
heben und so weiter also es war eine
katastrophe
sie hatten aber auch serbische nachbarn
die dort geblieben sind und das ist ein
wichtiger punkt weil immer wird so
geredet von ja die haben alle
gegeneinander gekämpft und so weiter da
möchte ich dem kollegen zu stimmen es
ist eigentlich für mich gar nicht so
komplex ist einfach eine frage von
faschismus und antifaschismus denn die
bosnische armee das war eine
multiethnische
multireligiöse armee mit geführt von
einem katholischen general der sogar in
einer arm
christdemokratischen partei aktiv war
und von einem serbischen general der
eigentlich in belgrad geboren war nach
bosnien kam um die leute anzugreifen
aber als er sah dass da ein
vernichtungskrieg geführt wird dass da
ein genozid passiert ist er desertiert
und hat sich hat die post erst
mitgegründet und deshalb es gibt so ein
gutes einen guten tipp den ich mal
gesehen habe zu dem thema zu dem thema
versöhnung wie können wir uns alle
versöhnen und so weiter und da hat
jemand geschrieben es gibt keine
versöhnung weil mit denjenigen serben
den genozid leugnen oder verharmlosen
werde ich mich nie versöhnen und mit
denjenigen serben die nicht leugnen oder
verharmlosen mit denen habe ich absolut
kein problem also was gibt es da zu
versöhnen
gibt es auch andere perspektiven darauf
die also wie wie wir das ganze serbisch
gedeutet damit gehen nicht sozusagen
einseitig das ganze betrachten sie haben
auch kontakt sicherlich auch mit mit
denen
oder ist das nicht sagt war weil wir
entweder mit denen zu tun haben die
ohnehin so denken wie sie und die
anderen die nicht so denken mit den
reden sie ohnehin nicht
empfinden sie hassen gegenüber also
gegenüber gernot leugnen natürlich das
gilt nicht nur für selbe schicksal das
gilt auch für leute die den holocaust
leugnen oder den genozid in ruanda oder
leute die einfach rassistisch sind und
so weiter das hat da einer modernen
gesellschaft keinen platz und leute die
das nicht machen mit denen habe ich
natürlich kein problem das ding ist
leider dass laut studien dort
forschungen
87 prozent der serben in bosnien den
genozid leugnen sie sagen dass mladic
der verurteilte völker dabei kein
verbrecher war 87 prozent sagen dass er
kein verbrecher und von den mickrigen 13
prozent die bleiben sagen bestimmt viele
okay war ein verbrecher aber war kein
fell kanada und so weiter und so fort
also da bleibt nur eine kleine
prozentzahl von mensch und was heißt das
eigentlich für das zusammenleben heute
dort meinen sie das 30 jahre noch so
wenig sind dass so etwas wie versöhnung
gemeinsames wieder aufbauen neue
erinnerungen schaffen noch ermöglicht
wird ich glaube bei allen volksgruppen
dominieren die national denkenden
parteien es ist natürlich sehr schlimm
den genozid zu leugnen aber
es wird eigentlich mit mit der
geschichte auch ein politisches geschäft
gemacht man sieht es jedes mal vor den
wahlen und bosnien steht jetzt vor den
wahlen im herbst da versuchen national
denkende politiker eigentlich diese
normative hoch zu schauen um die eigene
klientel zu mobilisieren damit sie damit
sie dann bei den wahlen auch für diese
national orientierten parteien auch
stimmen so können sie natürlich die
macht behalten und das spiel dauert
jetzt wirklich seit seit dem ende des
bosnienkrieges mit wenigen ausnahmen es
gibt natürlich kleine oasen
widerstandsnester zum beispiel in der
altstadt von sarajevo wo die
mehrheitlich muslimischen bürgerinnen
und bürger einen serben als
bürgermeister gewählt haben es gibt
kleine kulturinstitutionen krieg krieg
der in sarajevo
bosnisch muslimische schauspieler
kroatische schauspieler und serbischer
schauspieler zusammen spielen das sind
viele erfreuliche entwicklungen aber ich
glaube ich glaube was politisch in
bosnien geschichte es ist auf allen
seiten
unverantwortlich wie sie zum teil mit
der vergangenheit umgehen man will ja
keine aufarbeitung sondern sondern man
will eigentlich nur die eigenen opfer
oder eigenen archiv hervorheben um die
anderen zu erniedrigung und hier ist
natürlich die serbische seite
federführend
weil sie natürlich während des krieges
die meisten mittel hatten um die anderen
völker zu unterdrücken ja ja
ich habe weil sie das wort versöhnung
ausgesprochen haben war das eine gewisse
unwohl in ihnen zuhören ich frage mich
auch sie sehen auch gläubiger muslime
ich will sie jetzt nicht so erkenntnisse
verführen aber
was macht das mit ihrem glauben wir
reden von srebrenica 8000 menschen
mindestens wurden ermordet unschuldiger
menschen glauben sie wirklich noch an
einen gott der sich den namen frieden
gegeben hat wie es ja auch im koran 59
23 heißt und ist alles gut
wir glauben jetzt erst recht an einen
gott weil das sage ich immer wieder es
geht ja nicht nur ums trends das wird so
ein bisschen hervorgehoben weil es am
ende des krieges war damit man
verschweigen kann dass man die ersten
vier jahre nichts gemacht hat aber
in bosnien gab es schon seit anfang des
krieges konzentrationslager
vernichtungslager vergewaltigungs lager
weil wir waren ja gar keine menschen für
die serbischen nationalisten wir waren
genetisch entstelltes material und um
dieses genetisch entstellt material zu
säubern mussten bosniakische frauen also
bestens limas vergewaltigt werden zwangs
geschwängert werden um durch serbisches
blut gereinigt zu werden und so weiter
und so fort
weil die sachen auf die gerade im
glauben schwer machen nein weil das ding
ist nach all diesem schlimmen sachen
wurden ja die federführenden serbischen
nationalisten so ein bisschen bestraft
sitzen in den haag und so weiter aber
was ist mit all den zehntausenden leuten
die das gemacht haben die
die menschen erschossen haben und so
weiter das einzige was uns bleibt ist
glauben denn es gibt so viele menschen
in bosnien auch eine meiner besten
freundinnen die leben sofort neben den
menschen die verantwortlich sind für den
tod ihrer familienmitglieder sehen sie
jeden tag ich muss mir leicht weil wir
noch viel mehr miteinander diskutieren
sollten aber die zeit ein in der hat
ganz schnell die letzte frage stellen
sie sind beide ich habe nicht gefragt
was fasziniert mich an den beinen was
sie das verbindende von ihnen das ist
bestimmt nicht der balkan das ist nicht
die sprache die sie
verbindet auch die nicht die religiöse
zugehörigkeit sondern ihr unermüdlicher
haltung weiterhin über den krieg zu
schreiben gegen den krieg zu schreiben
den konflikt nicht loszulassen aber
wieso tun sie das wieso lassen sie mich
vom krieg hat ja weil das ist ja wohl
angst hätte dann einer unserer großen
treten sagte unsere vergangenheit ist
nicht vergangen
es prägt immer noch unser leben wenn ich
zum beispiel ich pendle mal
zwischendurch deutschland und bosnien
wenn ich sehe dass in deutschland dieses
alle seiten narrativ herrscht wo wir
wissen dass 95 prozent aller schweren
kriegsverbrechen von der serbischen
seite begonnen begann wurden vier
prozent von der kroatischen 1 prozent
alle anderen zusammen jetzt gezielt und
dann wird uns irgendwas von allen seiten
verkauft das kann ich nicht so stehen
lassen weil es ist auch eine gefahr für
heute serbische nationalismus
für uns kurze antworten
ich glaube die menschen haben es
verdient gehört zu werden das ist
eigentlich die hauptmotivation für mich
auch wenn ich zum beispiel an
jahrestagen in srebrenica bin und man
sieht dann es ist immer spannend zu
sehen
welche autos und mit welchen
autokennzeichen herumfahren in
srebrenica darf kommen menschen aus ganz
europa sind verstreut in ganz europa und
die kommen nur für diesen tag ist ein
tag wo so ein bisschen würde zurückkehrt
wo sie eigentlich die die die die
knochen der opfer der familienmitglieder
zusammen sammeln können und beerdigen in
einer würdigen zeremonie
und für mich war das signal ergreifen zu
sehen dass da überhaupt keine
hassparolen ausgestoßen wurden das
begründet warum sie weiterhin vom krieg
schafft lassen haben sie vielen dank für
das erhellende und wichtige spricht
nächste woche begrüßt olivenöl im haus
der religionen in bern in der
streitfrage
geht es um die erweiterte
widerspruchslösung
also um die frage sollen menschen die
sich nie konkret dazu geäußert haben und
deren verwandte einverstanden sind
automatisch so potenzielle organspender
rehman spendern werden ihnen einen
nachdenklichen sonntag
[Musik]